to understand how many Americans deal
with their dead there may be no better
place to visit than the oldest embalming
school in the u.s. the Cincinnati
College of mortuary science or CCMS
since 1882 generation after generation
of morticians and training have come to
CCMS to become experts in the American
rituals of death and burial my friends
and I told him that I was going into the
funeral business they all just kind of
give me the same look like you want to
work with dead people erricka Kaiser's
uncle owns a funeral home where she
worked during college there's just so
many ghost stories and misconceptions
about the the field that and people are
just too afraid to find out what it's
all about all cultures have ways of
handling dead bodies but most american
christians don't realize that how they
treat their dead makes them different
from nearly every other culture in the
world america is one of the few places
where corpses are routinely embalmed
american funeral directors know that
their clients want the dead to look as
they did in life think in the eyes of a
family they want to see their loved one
in a very natural peaceful state in the
US the goal of embalmers is not just a
disguised deaths pallor but to stop its
inevitable destruction in its tracks
this body donated to the school is
already decomposing but Erica and her
classmates will stop the decay for as
long as a few years by injecting the
corpse with several gallons of a
chemical preservative based on
formaldehyde this American practice of
routinely embalming the dead would be
taboo in many other cultures even in
mortuary school embalming is practically
a ritual with clearly defined steps
first the body is cleaned and prepped
mouths pleasure it's crucial to get that
very natural next the embalmers locate
the blood vessel into which they will
pump the formaldehyde solution and you
have to work your way through that
go ahead and cut the artery as the
embalming fluid enters the body it
displaces the blood which escapes
through an incision usually in the
jugular vein almost immediately the
corpse begins to harden this may seem
like a process dreamed up by a mad
scientist but in reality embalming has
deep historical and religious roots in
America embalming arose not from a quest
for immortality but from perhaps the
nation's greatest tragedy the Civil War
modern embalming techniques had just
been invented when hundreds of thousands
of young men began dying on battlefields
far from home for the first time
soldiers families could request that the
bodies of their sons and husbands be
preserved and returned for burial there
were many who welcomed the new technique
as a godsend
many Christians saw embalming as a
perfect fit with their religious beliefs
in which the body and the spirit would
be reunited at the resurrection as
diverse as the rituals we practice to
honor the dead to heal our grief we're
united in our need to mark this most
final of all life's passages and to
attempt to make sense of what must
remain a mystery